росіяни досягли кульмінації росіяни
більше нічого не можуть вдіяти
тривалість війни значною мірою
залежатиме від того чи зробимо мете Що
обіцяли чи поставимо ми все озброєння
яке обіцяли Я вважаю що до кінця цього
року ми можемо відкинути їх до лінії 23
лютого
генерали ходжеса ви разом з іншими
членами трансатлантичного співтовариства
безпеки США підписала відкритий лист в
якому йдеться що Західна військова
підтримка допомогла створити батову
ситуацію на лінії фронту в Україні але
її недостатньо для того щоб Київ зміг
повернути території завойовані Росією
чого не вистачає
не вистачає спроможності України
розпочати рішучий успішний Контрнаступ
здатний відкинути російські війська
назад до лінії 23 лютого українці були
неймовірно стійкими ефективними
новаторськими але їм потрібна більш
далекобійна і точно артилерія артилерія
ракети які можуть стріляти далі які
можуть продовжувати знищувати російську
артилерію
логістику завдавати ударів по російських
аеродромах Ось що потрібно ми надали
дещо але цього недостатньо для
вирішального ефекту Ось чому вже близько
місяця лінія фронту практично не
змінюється росіяни досягли кульмінації
росіяни більше нічого не можуть вдіяти
але українцям необхідно спроможність
перемогти І це те що ми маємо для них
зробити
[музика]
міністр оборони України виключив
можливість української армії завдавати
ударів дальністю 300 кілометрів чи
постачатиме зрештою уряд США таку зброю
здається що до цього є згода як серед
американських республіканців так і серед
демократів
я сподіваюся на це ми мусимо
Я думаю що адміністрація байдена провела
дуже добру роботу за винятком цієї
частини
де вони як на мене переоцінюють
потенціал ескалації з російської сторони
і коли пан сальван каже що Ми не хочемо
ризикувати початком третьої світової
війни
він значно переоцінює те що може статися
Росія не має нічого іншого що вона могла
б зробити крім Як застосувати ядерну
зброю
Я вважаю вкрай малої ймовірним що вони
застосують ядерну зброю на території
України
для них немає жодної Вигоди від цього
немає цілей яку вони могли вразити щоб
змінити перебіг бойових дій у
сприятливий для себе бік
Я вважаю якщо Росія застосує ядерну
зброю то Сполучені Штати та
Великобританія не зможуть залишитися
осторонь Я також не вірю що Путін
божевільний він злий але він не
божевільний і не самогубець І я також
думаю що 70 чи десь стільки олігархів
які утримують його при владі не хочуть
щоб все сталося
тому я думаю що білий дім перебільшує чи
переоцінює ризик ескалації але оскільки
Вашингтон так робить Ми продовжуємо
надавати допомогу по чайній ложці
замість того щоб дати необхідні обсяги
зброї
6 чи 5 місяців тому уточилися суперечки
про те чи маємо ми надавати стіни ЗСУ
було побоювання що якщо українець зіб'є
російський вертоліт американським
стінгаром
то це може призвести до ескалації тепер
це видається безглуздим
Я маю на увазі що зараз коли ми
піднімалися на наступну сходинку росіяни
нічого не робили бо вони не здатні
нічого зробити
Тому це єдина частина кампанії де на мій
погляд Адміністрація Президента
помиляється
повертаючись до ситуації на фронті
України яка ваша оцінка ви щойно згадали
Що росіяни не можуть більше просуватися
вперед але й українці не мають такої
можливості однак удари по Криму мали
великий ефект Що на вашу думку
відбувається наразі росіяни досягли
кульмінації тієї стадії яку клаузівець
називає кульмінаційним моментом коли
одна сторона більше не може продовжувати
наступ коли більше немає ресурсів людей
чи енергії з тих чи інших причин Те чим
зараз займається українці Я думаю що
вони готуються чи створюють умови для
того щоб розпочати Контрнаступ
це означає що вони роблять усе можливе
щоб знищити російську артилерію ракети
порушити логістику та ускладнити для
росіян командування та керування
знищуючи російські командні пункти
і щоразу коли вони завдають удар по
складах з боєприпасами А це відбувається
Приблизно два рази на тиждень росіянам
доводиться переміщувати їх все далі І
далі від лінії фронту
це ще більше ускладнює ситуацію бо тепер
ватажкам доводиться возити боєприпаси на
більш далекі відстані
і тому ми вже бачимо позитивний ефект
кількість російських артилерійських та
ракетних обстрілів різко скоротилася це
свідчить про те що Україна зараз створює
умови для контрнаступу є і психологічний
аспект
росіяни насправді невпевнені що вони
знають що саме сталося в Криму
звісно Вони завжди кажуть що це був
нещасний випадок пожежа щось таке бо для
них принизливо визнавати що українці
можуть завдати ударів по аеродромах та
залізницях у Криму який Звичайно є
суверенною українською територією
але Річ у тому що вони не можуть
захистити свої тели вони вразливі ви
напевно знаєте що під час Другої
світової війни на східному фронті
німецький Вермахт
був змушений виділяти сотні тисяч
солдатів лише для охорони залізниць в
Україні та Білорусі
бо треба було захищати логістику у
росіян немає достатньої кількості людей
чи можливостей для цього це показує що
вони вразливі це також підкреслює що
їхня логістична система виснажена
маю на увазі що вони не можуть
замінювати оснащення це складно
Якщо ви уявите собі сучасну гаубицю
артилерійську або ракетну установку там
так багато запчастин яким необхідним
мастила обслуговування і ви маєте це
робити усі ці деталі мають бути в
наявності усе це тягар для дуже крихкої
вразливої логістичної системи
і останнє якщо дозволите мені було дуже
цікаво дивитися відео про атаку на
аеродром Саки у Криму
усі ваші телеглядачі теж бачили як
російський туристи на пляжі побачили
вибух лише за кілька кілометрів від
місця де вони знаходилися
а наступного дня міст через керченську
протоку був забитий тисячами машин які
намагалися виїхати та повернутися до
Росії
три речі привернули мою увагу перше
як дивно що росіяни відпочивають у Криму
здається їх не хвилює що Буквально за
кілька кілометрів від них вбивають
російських солдатів
значить вони нічого не знають
або Вони настільки зрозумілі або
імбайдуже це перше друга думка яка у
мене виникла якщо Крим це свята земля Як
каже Путін
то чому ці тисячі чоловіків та жінок не
пішли на найближчу військову базу і не
сказали Я готовий боротися Я хочу її
захищати
це тому що вони знають що це не Росія і
саме тому вони розуміють що їм там не
місце і саме тому вони робили усе
можливе щоб вибратися звідти через таку
відсутність реальної підтримки Я думаю
зусилля Росії не довговічні
далекобійні засоби артилерія - це одне
однак багато українських солдатів гинуть
через те що їм доводиться добиратися до
лінії фронту на простих пікапах та інших
автівках кілька місяців тому Німеччина
виключила можливість постачання в
Україну бдр типу фукс що ви думаєте про
цю позицію зараз
Я знаю що Німеччина поставила 15
зенітних самохідних установок гепард і
ще 15 збирається поставити Це дуже добре
бойова машина звичайно вона не
призначена для перевезення війська але
забезпечує дуже ефективну наземну
вогневу підтримку і боротьбу з
безпілотниками тож це вже зроблено крім
того пан Серга обіцяв 2000 це дуже
потужна артилерія
українці уже навчилися їх
використовувати Але я думаю що лише
близько 50%. з них Наразі функціонують
це не дуже добре Я розчарований тим що
Німеччина не надала більше я розумію
причину Але я думаю що якби Німеччина
хотіла надати більше
вона могла б це зробити
Німеччина має бути якщо не лідером то
одним із лідерів у Європі але щоб бути
нормальним лідером якого всі поважають
за його моральний університет а також за
його економічну міць та решту добрих
речей Німеччина має виглядати як союзник
України в її перемозі над Росією якщо
Україна не переможе Росію чи це
затягнеться надовго або якщо Україна
переможе Росію без реальної допомоги
Німеччини то ніхто не поважатиме ФРН
Росія не поважатиме Німеччину інші
європейські країни не поважатимуть
Німеччину Мені здається що ми
знаходимося на тому етапі коли Німеччина
може стати лідером у Європі коли вона
може позитивно вплинути на все те що
настурбує але також є відчуття що нині
ми знаходимося на тому етапі коли цей
вплив майже змістився на Схід у бік
країн Балтії і Польщі та на північ тому
Німеччина має діяти Берлін має зробити
так щоб ФРН сприймали як країну яка
допомагає Україні перемогти
навіщо Україні зброя часів холодної
війни Як ви гадаєте чому це може бути
важливим
навіть старі леопарди дуже добра зброя
Тобто це якісні танки і я думаю що коли
настане час розпочати Контрнаступ
українцям потрібен буде цей потенціал
для того щоб мати те що ми називаємо
захищеною мобільною вогневою потужністю
танк - це Актив який допоможе їм і знову
ж таки я не розумію небажання німецького
уряду брати участь у цьому Дозвольте
мені сформулювати інакше я розумію деякі
причини але зараз настав той момент коли
німці мають вирішити де вони і як
Німеччина бачать свою роль у світі
і наприкінці запитаю п Генерала як довго
ще триватиметься війна яким може бути її
результат
тривалість війни значною мірою
залежатиме від того чи зробимо мете Що
обіцяли чи поставимо ми все озброєння
яке обіцяли чи поставимо його вчасно чи
забезпечимо українців тим що їм
необхідно Я вважаю що оскільки російська
армія Стала такою слабкою до кінця цього
року ми можемо відкинути їх до лінії 23
лютого до кінця цього року
а згодом Крим Донбас територія до 23
лютого чи 24 лютого
Я думаю цього можна досягти в найближче
рік-д-2
можливо шляхом переговорів або інших
подібних речей
але принаймні повернення до лінії 23
лютого реальне до кінця цього року
якщо ми виконаємо те що пообіцяли
Якщо ми цього не зробимо Це те на що
розраховує Кремль
розраховує на те що США втратить інтерес
через інфляцію
власні внутрішні проблеми та проміжні
вибори
Великобританія все ще шукає нового
прем'єр-міністра
Німеччина занепокоєна наслідками
скорочення постачання газу арені зараз
дуже змінив
усе це ті речі які як думають росіяни
будуть гальмувати нас це є ключовим
моментом якщо вони виявляться правими то
ця війна затягнеться на роки